je vous écoute aujourd'hui jeu super
content parce que la vidéo d'hier soir à
plus de 20000 commentaires si l'une des
vidéos les plus commandés ces six
derniers mois donc je pose que vous
l'avez grandement apprécié vous avez une
le dire dans les commentaires
oh la belle barbe [ __ ] la barre de
squeeze viril les gars squeeze viril la
virilité squeeze de la barbe suspect oh
mon dieu labarthe a changé squeeze et
most
comment
john a
ok ok ok il est vrai la barbe a poussé
pendant ces deux semaines aux états unis
et je pensais pas que ça vous marque
rotor mais apparemment ça vous marque
allait ouvrir vos l'ifp h 47 et lisons
tout ça avec la barre je lui donne 30
ans je sais je suis viennent ils dommage
la voix je lui donne quinze ans je sais
mais elle tamar fait viril arrêté ouais
ça va pousser mais il a toujours son
corps de lâche alors ça alors ça ça
c'est vrai je suis le seul qui a
remarqué qu'il ya un projet jeunes
enjoués derrière squeeze [ __ ] enfin
qu'un gars qui parle pas de barbe et qui
parle de corsen c'est le personnage d'un
manga qui s'appelle assassination
classroom voilà [ __ ] race toi mec
bruno bruno autour de faire le chemin
garçons tabarre que donne ce petit côté
kawaii croyons que j'ai changé
voilà je voulais remonter c'est gratuit
il me ressemble à ces prières se laisser
pousser la barbe pour la barbe cyprien
déjà à jeff avoir 26 ans et ensuite quoi
laisser pousser pendant un an sans les
toucher phrase la barbe était mieux son
sérieux like et si vous êtes d'accord
écoute nofal giffard ictu à un like
voilà j'en conclus que je ne vois pas la
raser
j'adore il fait que ce cas et c'est la
barbe jetez vous palau que j'ai vu dans
des années dans les films d mais qu ils
réfléchissent qui se grattent la barbe
comme ça du coup j'en profite et je fais
aussi et c'est instinctif fins et n'a
pas voulu qu est ce que je peux dire
ensuite comme oh pardon exprès là ici tu
trouves que la barbe ça lui va bien je
trouve qu'il ressemble plus à un mec qui
faisait la virilité ma gueule mdr j'ai
pas trop comprendre ce commentaire est
sciemment je ressemblais du coup à une
sorte de femmes 317 like plus tard on
veut c'est quoi aulas à l'effet you to
want célèbre quiz gens resteront pour
une nouvelle vidéo s'enflammait je suis
sûr que la prochaine vidéo parlera de sa
barbe 70% des commentaires sont à propos
de la barre basque ouï dire non je suis
originales comme youtube heures je ferai
jamais ça pourquoi squeeze parce que ça
fait zizir je mérite combien d'années de
prison monsieur le juge de 30 ans omg
cette barbe est magnifique je suis ému
merci mr nenê oui moi aussi je suis ému
tous les matins je me dis [ __ ] ça pis
il en attend ça ça fait six ans d'un
corps de lâcher pas de virilité et là on
a au moins l'un des deux ça fait plaisir
tu as trop de barbe j'aime pas moins un
bon d'accord on pas carrément sur des
abonnements on est question esthétique
je pensais pas comme cet homme en
ballons joués avec soin le grand et
magnifique squeeze arrêter de faire de
vraies vidéos maintenant je pense me
désabonner josée chabot j'ai une
question est posée quelle vidéo pour toi
est une vraie vidéo je mérite de gym
pour a refait les remakes même une vidéo
dans laquelle le créatrice était pas
moins choisi j'ai même pas suivi la
vidéo tellement sa barbe et cybèle la
culture pécho taille qui fait la marque
tube hey oh je me paie choix en plus tu
t'appelles trou noir black hole ça
m'excite un peu tout ça iwata suivant
omg nos petits
vous et viril notre enfant est devenu un
vrai petit enfant est devenu grand tu es
super gros caractères butin les gens qui
disent aux squeeze elle bart incroyable
ses comptes problème n'a jamais vu une
barbouze
et hop hop hop au rendez vous c'est
sûrement le fait que vous n'avez pas
encore car vous n'avez que 13 ans et que
vous jouer à minecraft aulas
je
je trouve que cette barbe de quelques
jours lui va très bien mdr lol squeeze
pourquoi tu mets un casque alors qu'il
n'y a pas de son et coup j'essaie poussé
pendant trois semaines c'est vrai mais
non mais ses réserves il est obligé de
le mettre dans toutes les vidéos ouais
ouais ouais c'est vrai mais pas du tout
c'est juste un réflexe en tête mouawad
mito placement gros du placement de
produits au cap et à la barbe de ouf de
squeeze laïque et si vous aussi vous
trouvez qu'il a une super barbe n'a
aucun narcissisme dans ce que je viens
faire un [ __ ] ça j'adore je suis une
grande fan de squeeze ou du moins je
l'étais je trouve que ces vidéos sont
beaucoup moins intéressante je trouve
personnellement que les vidéos sont
devenus commercial
c'est ce qui est beau dans cette
histoire nice c'est que tu as le même
nom de famille que moi voilà le reste
c'est pas beau la maturité du jeu
précédent a fait comprendre à ta barbe
qu'il était temps de pousser où elle a
pris une substance quelconque je fais
appel à l'inspecteur squeeze dont
j'avais les fait passer avant j'allais
bon papa c'est quoi cette petite me
barre là en fait face aux us pour deux
semaines et je me suis jamais rasé non
pas mal poussé ducouret ça me fait une
grosse barbe de bach beat offert mes
amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo mais
jusqu'où nous poussera cette barre
rejoindront nous les plus grands
où les plus petits
nous ne pouvons pas savoir mais je suis
fier de vous annoncer qu'après cinq ans
d'attenté un début de vérité est enfin
apparu encore une fois merci à tous
d'avoir
cru en ma virilité depuis le d'accord le
générique qui veut car non pas que je
remercie
oh
sinon c'est ma vidéo je peux peut-être
[Musique]
et où tu vas détente générée commun
abonnez vous